and the spirit award for best supporting
male actor
i was trying to figure this out
backstage nobody knew so
i'm the first to know
troy concert
[Applause]
this is troy kotzer's first spirit award
nomination and win
the film's name coda stands for child of
deaf adults
wow
well
here we are thank you so much all of you
i'm so touched
that all of us artists are under the
same roof right now i can feel the
spirit of the arts and we can celebrate
together
thank you so much for everyone who has
recognized my work and i'm so proud to
be a part of this peer group with so
many talented nominees
my character
frank rossi
is really the difference between
gloucester massachusetts and here in
santa monica is that a deaf fisherman
can't afford a beer in santa monica
it's expensive you know
and so it's really interesting to
compare the two places so our community
out there in massachusetts in gloucester
i'm so grateful to the entire
fishing community our ship captain and
everyone in the community of gloucester
who supported our film coda
and so thank you
to our producers
i'd like to recognize
patrick waxberg
and philippe rossella
who really put the faith in our project
to plant that seed that blossomed at
sundance and flowered into an apple tree
and this apple
began to roll into hollywood and so
thank you so much i love you marley i
love you daniel
i love you eugenio and amy
and ferdia and sean are director too so
the spirit is here and that apple has
tumbled into hollywood
and so it's an important movie thank you
so much and thanks to my wife and my
daughter who aren't here tonight but
their spirit is
love you all
[Applause]
[Music]
you